the Joe Rogan experience so tell me more
about your book uh why are you why are
you breaking um these buildings so
that's a dog whistle
that's a dog was the cover so there's a
guy named Ben garrison and he was a
regular conservative artist right and he
would have drawings about like Ben
Bernanke or Hillary or whatever the
Nazis took his art replaced all of his
drawings with Jews so instead of the
great wizard of debt being the Fed it
was a Jewish caricature and they did it
perfectly and they also invented this
whole backstory about him that he was
this closet Nazi and this poor guy in
Montana if you google him it's like
knots and he's like why is this
happening to me and the Photoshop work
is perfect so eventually they calm down
and you know now he's kind of like a
regular cartoonist in this story got out
but that's his artwork so the people
this poor guy who was talking about a
victim of Nazis it's very rare nowadays
to have a new victim of Nazis and he's
actually one of them well meme culture
is very strange right yes and those
little humorous images that get chucked
around oh yeah there's a lot of dirtbag
sort of really profited off of other
people's meme work too I like my friend
Don he's terrible he works for a meme
site yeah dirtbag those sites are bad
man some of them just flat-out steal and
some of them steal and then they'll
attribute oh yeah yeah yeah I'm where
like they'll just say your name and
sometimes they don't even say your name
they say a name of like a fake account
that doesn't even distribute it to
someone oh we caught we got it from that
person because they know that it's at a
hundred different account yeah but
because bunch of people have this guy's
like you you'll find something you like
oh this is funny and you put it up but
then there's people that they make these
giant sites with all other people's work
and they curate them yeah and they make
millions yep like a fat Jewish yeah oh
yeah everyone hates him they say oh this
is one of you this is like one of your
big issues with like people who like
take content and basically agree to be
appropriate for themselves but first for
sure with stand-up comedy yeah but the
thing that's happening with memes is
like you're you if someone sends you
something like there's a bunch of things
that Mike Eddie Bravo sends me for
hilarious ones all the time
he'll send me a funny meme and then I'll
send it to Brendan Schaub and I'm not
asking who made that me
so but a joke Brendon doesn't think that
I made it myself
so it's not like I'm stealing my joke
but I'm definitely not crediting the
original creator because I don't know
who the [ __ ] it is right and those
things fly around they flower out so but
that's all with in good faith the person
with in bad faith right curates a
website and then starts profiting off of
it they find a loophole and then they
make deals with Comedy Central and then
they also have people who actually steal
stand-ups bits and turn those bits in
the memes and they put those bits on
there they're mean pages and they do the
same [ __ ] they'll do it they just their
content need ears they need content
they're [ __ ] parasites yes so they
just they'll hire people to do it they
in the people that they hire they'll
they'll steal people's jokes and turn
them into memes it's real it's a real
problem that's that's I mean that's it
become a joke because like people are
like oh this is a rare pepe right just
like please say it's just like you know
even though you can replicate you know
the Pepe lawsuit I talk about that in
there no the new one that's happening
right now Alex Jones refused to he
refused to settle out of court
so they're gonna go to court they're
gonna figure out whether or not Pepe you
can use Pepe the Frog but I mean I
talked about this in the context of it's
like if King Andy Warhol uses Campbell's
soup can it's the same thing it's like
if yes someone creates it but if someone
is using it in a kind of a broader
satirical context well it doesn't though
because Andy probably couldn't do that
today yes he could I think they'd soon
if we tried to make a lot of money off
of Campbell's and cans corporations had
more power back then and less
accountability because now with social
media everyone lose their minds on
Campbell's right that's true that's a
good point I think that you know what
they did with Campbell's did when he did
this so he paints all 40 flavors of soup
cans right puts him up in a gallery
Campbell is just like what the [ __ ] is
this like they didn't know what to do
right and they didn't know who to call
this is unprecedented so they had a
storefront and they had the cans of the
window they go why pay a hundred grand
you could get it here for a dollar so
they tried to own it in their own way
that's smart that's smart great
advertising for them yeah I mean
gigantic advertising but that's the
other thing is like with this meme
culture people like Oh Pepe means white
supremacy
it's like you can't Campbells doesn't
say what a Campbell Soup can means
different things mean this is not news
different things mean different things
to different people
and if you're using it in one context
doesn't mean other contexts aren't
legitimate that's how art and images
work yeah I mean that's almost like what
happened with the guy in Montana right
so yes his work and then turns it into
Nazi stuff and all sudden he becomes a
knob right they do with it with Pepe the
Frog cuz that guy who met Harry yeah
he's so upset
I know because he didn't they did to him
he had a cartoon where he killed Pepe so
all the trolls are like oh that's
interesting so they took all his other
characters and made them full-blown
Nazis so Heinrich who's the wolf instead
of having reflections in a sunglasses
had the SS they're like oh you wanna you
want to throw it out we'll throw down
[ __ ] and that's what happened here
wolf has a Nazi name already no now they
gave my last name it's like Heinrich
something else but that name I'll tell
you what I mean oh my god I know no Nazi
what do they call it
that's a Nazi wolf yeah I cannot see
what maybe they what was that that's
hilarious it he thought he could just
kill it off that's like deep platforming
he thought is get a deep platformer Pepe
what's also like let's suppose I decide
to kill off Paul Bunyan but the [ __ ]
how I can't what I mean doesn't mean
anything like the idea that he's gonna
kill it off and they're gonna stop were
killed his name was originally land wolf
so they said his first name is Heinrich
land wolf and the son Eva pull it up and
the glasses well maybe we should have a
symmetry here but and wolf as opposed to
what sky the funny thing is about Pepe
was it was always so blue hand and lame
well like before it was adopted as a
meme like when you say like feels bad
man right like it was like this is so
low blood sugar bothers me